hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to guys
you are in for a treat this is one of
those special special films that only
comes around once in a while a film that
should make me angry to my boiling point
but it's just so awful it's pretty much
wonderful it is a wonderful movie so
anxious to get to it olive oil waste any
time so this is Dungeons & Dragons
much like the room troll - or the ælis
library of Schwarzenegger movies don't
jhin's and Dragons is one of those rare
films that simply gets everything raw
the casting is wrong
the writing is wrong the story is wrong
the effects are wrong where did I go
right in this strange combination
somehow turns out a beautiful beautiful
butterfly of absolute horribleness it's
a bad film of epic proportions and we're
gonna look at it today get ready to slap
your head in confusion until it goes
numb this it's Dungeons and Dragons so
after we see the company that will
ironically release Lord of the Rings one
year later we get some opening narration
the Empire of Izmir has long been a
divided land ruled by the mages an elite
group of magic users already I'm
confused those without magic a little
more than slaves and already I don't
care it's pretty impressive for under
one minute so we get our first shot of
this mirror as we venture into the
secret lair of our villain
sorry I'm sorry nothing funny zapping
yet I'm just I'm just preparing for it
I'm sorry I'm sorry it's just if you
seen this movie before you'll start
laughing around this part - there he is
Jeremy Irons give him a round of
applause everybody he's gonna bring us
so much joy in this hour and a half
you're an attractive Sapta aren't you oh
yeah wait I've seen this that Mickey
Mouse comes out and steals a big pointy
hat no wait no no I'm sorry that's a
it's another one for the top cartoon
yeah
oh boy it's gonna be one of those
non-acting days isn't it
I think they got this dragon on loan
from how to train your CGI artist
yes I told you it could be done you have
the power of the Immortals I get also
you can control dragons tell you god
damn you very I'm your rage
alright now your party you give me power
your very pocket ragged gasping give me
sassy oh you're so satyr yesterday your
dirty little kitty aren't you acting so
this delightful dish of ham and cheese
is our villain the evil sorcerer prophy
on prophy on hmm
so it sounds like a heartburn medication
doesn't it are you Thai out of orgasming
every senior in why don't you try the
mystical wonders of propia it's magic in
a tiny tablet side effects may include
overacting mugging and inability to be
good movies but it's scepter doesn't
work for very long and thus they have to
kill the dragon
no I am the last one the dragon's blood
leads into the river which causes it to
subtly catch fire because dragon's blood
does that gotta be some twisted magic
experiment gone seriously wrong just
love to find a way to give those made
you some payback
oh yeah Rindy to save you and these I am
sad to say are our two main heroes a
couple of thieves named Ridley played by
justin Whelan and snails played by
Marlon Wayans I'll give you one guess
how they casted him for the part what's
that
Chris Tucker isn't able to do it alright
let's go to the weigh ins wheel come on
after talking about breaking into the
Magic School to steal some supplies we
see that a meeting is going on between
profion and the big Council of who gives
a fuck they discuss what is to be done
with the controversial views of the
Empress but we have all watched the
Empress's growing up and we have all
heard her views on what she considers to
be the injustice is over there but she
is just a young woman young people speak
from the heart not the mind
ouch well okay let's hear from the side
that's defending the Empress oh that was
her side so that government in Izmir
will remain secure
remove the sceptre which lowers above
our heads and destroy the threat of
revolution forever can I get an amen
we will be forced to do whatever we must
to protect the state an identity of his
man what say you give us Barabbas
Barabbas we then cut to the Emperor's
played by Thora Birch discussing why her
ideas are being tossed aside and why
she's being called the Obama of the
fantasy world all people deserve to be
free and equal with a commoner a mage I
know this within the depths of my soul
yeah you can see her memorizing her
lines for Ghost World right now this
rules just work off a speeding ticket
what can I do to stop profil you must
outsmart him I'm not that on a sub rail
with one wave of it
I will topple her is this guy just on an
all Smurfs diet seriously what's with
the toothpaste hastily on his lip see
our friend ville de persuade him to give
you the scroll of which he speaks and
bring it here to me so we cut to all
right the library of the Magic School
and thus enters our hot nerdy chick for
the evening marina played by Zoe
McLellan sorry that's all right my job
but you must understand the seriousness
about Tosca
I know it's just that I feel like I
should be doing something more than
shelving rise I'm just an Marina yes my
Disney Princess heart is just begging
for something more
catch me semantical wing oh that's all
the development I get huh
okay I go so really and snails break
into the school and look for something
to steal are you gonna jump you gotta
catch me how do you catch you Emily I
promise now jump now I'm betting that
he's gonna just catch him and absolutely
nothing is gonna go wrong at all
Oh way to play with my expectations good
sirs well done gentlemen well done I
think that calls for a very affectionate
wah-wah
put it back come on just reporting it
back here about gold it's too big
put it back hmm
but marina finds the two and tries to
capture them you're thieves trying to
rob us expended his comic relievers that
must be the only way to get guys to come
home with her I'd have to put a feeble
mind spell on myself to want to take you
home snap so they're literally roped
into the situation as slurpy lip here
tries to get some information out of the
whiskey if you don't tell me which
scroll it is I'll have to kill him
painfully never you know you've got
something on your so the bad guys are
looking for a map that leads to a magic
scepter that apparently can control red
dragons but marina gets it in time and
uses the portal from sliders to escape
dragon the thieves with her
and you just ran into that garbage you
can see it coming a mile away
Danah body gotta focus it's around here
Ayano hey it's the missing seventh dwarf
smelly dude dwarves helmet stop them
from having epileptic seizures seriously
him a dark Archer get together and be
clucking buddies they bring the dwarf
with and escape through the sewers but
the captain of the guard says with great
speed what he wants his men to do post
brigades at every sewer exit um you know
sir if you said your orders a little
faster we could get them done a little
quicker by the way they got something
I'm here so the captain puts out a
wanted poster for the Little Mermaid but
our heroes blend into their environment
by wearing incredibly suspicious black
clothes that nobody else seems to be
wearing meanwhile you stop moving the
camera goddamn it with a fuck shooting
distant drum George Jetson Jane stop
this crazy thing
not right so the blue M&M here tells /
fee and why the heroes got away it was a
mistake it will not happen again and
here's why
well I don't like the weird things in my
head making me do the weird faces and
things while now it's going to the
nether regions not a fan not a fan dial
maybe and I make some weird great they
made sense the thing believed my nether
regions alone and I will be happy again
down no now I'll never be able to wear a
hat is needed to cover my incredibly
bold hand and one that point Lyman i mr.
clean the moment you deliver me the rod
i'll ensure that he is vacate the
premises now may I suggest okaywe're
Porter lying bad touch territory right
now it's not officially there yet but
it's dangerously gone now or in bad
touch territory yeah you should call a
lawyer guy how much well bet that's the
Christmas card season's greetings from
pro Fionna and Baldy please don't ask
why his lips to kiss me so our heroes
take cover and the most non suspicious
tavern that the city has
our main characters look over the map
and seem to really get into it really
get into it
hey - del - ah - go okay what chapstick
here is about to sneak into the place do
you think you can say your orders a
little faster seeing how time is of the
essence ooh not let them escape or you
will suffer a fate far worse than that
which hath been inflicted upon me don't
make me poke my lips anymore so he
enters the place and finds the people
he's looking for
wait wait wait for what the right there
just nag oh it's a good thing you waited
those couple of seconds or else it would
have been a lot harder to let them
escape so really a morena get out of the
map and he informed snail that he's
agreed to help her find the scepters
which is weird considering how a few
seconds ago she wanted to leave and now
she can't imagine doing the mission
without but how could you do something
like that I don't even get it what was
he indicating when he was pointing at
them does he think they had sex while
they were in the map is I even doable I
mean granted map sex sounds pretty kinky
but I would hold off alright so if I got
this right they have to get the red
scepter in order to control the Red
Dragons but first they had to find this
Ruby called the I the dragon which opens
the door that leads to the red scepter
but the I the dragon can only begun in
this den of thieves which is ruled by
this guy he won't give you the eye the
dragon unless you defeat this evil maze
which nobody has ever conquered but
before you can do that you have to trade
your rubies with the old man in order to
upgrade your sword once you find the
secret passage you can then work your
way through the forest defeat the evil
dragon get the Triforce of power that
yeah yeah you get the idea so they
follow this purple guy who has an eye
vagina on his head and leads them to the
den of thieves we're riff raff from the
Rocky Horror Picture Show await them
have you ever heard of the anteus guild
maze just a jump to the neck
he has the ruby key they're looking for
but really has to get through this
deadly maze in order to win it I thought
this was Dungeons & Dragons not mazes
and monsters
yeah tell me if this looks enough think
that's bad take a look at this see he
can only step on the square with the red
eye where all the other squares will
lead to his do remind you of anything
else remember the Latin alphabet Jehovah
begins with an i yeah well they're all
eyes what the hell am I supposed to do
how about this the closing ceiling was
spikes on ya again ring any bells well
on the bright side I can't see them
ripping off anymore India jumbo come on
it's like an exact replica are you even
trying to be original George Lucas must
be rolling in his grave but the soldiers
once again come in to seize the heroes
oh yeah but be prepared for a lesson in
pain there's only room for one
overacting bald guy in this movie you
must be joking I never joke when majors
trespass in my kill the boiler were you
got something under the captain captures
marina and the other three escaped they
come across a tracker who's been working
for the Empress a saucy little elf named
Norton is that the elf you were drooling
over well I wouldn't put it that way but
yeah that's up pretty huh they all look
alike to me
whoa hey side of the dwarf - never seen
before anyone so Nora tells the Empress
the situation through get a load this a
magic mirror I have unfortunate tidings
to report it seems profile also seeks
the rod seek Damodar out we need that
rod as you wish you know she's prettier
than you so we see that the captain is
going to interrogate marina trying to
get some information out of her
once the question is don't work he
resorts to this
okay this has to be the point where they
knew their careers were over nobody can
come back from a scene this stupid you
know for a movie called Dungeons and
Dragons I've seen a dungeon and a dragon
could you show us something a little
more meaty outside of earwax rape oh
well how about brilliant snails break
into the place and try to rescue marina
Nordo and all her soldiers just stay
behind and watch them why this task they
must complete alone okay so really a
snail split up and eventually one of
them finds marina
I was crying I was afraid I would see
you again
but snails comes across a quick rug and
get snatched by lipgloss here just like
you thieves always taking things that
don't belong to you well that is what if
he does isn't that sort of like saying
you painters always painting now a man
oh oh oh
wise guy so again snails runs as fast as
he can but the captain of the guards
goes as slowly as possible
idiot figured out yet that doing
everything slowly doesn't work in his
favor
you cannot be serious he finally catches
up to snails but really a marine are
there to try and save it however it
turns out snails stole the map and
tosses it to them
Jesus yeah I know I should feel sorry
for him but you have no idea how
annoying this character once this is
incredibly satisfying
so marina uses her magic just as f the
captain and get them out of there
leaving the poor corpse of Wayans behind
we think that's appropriate at the
Empress whose dress looks like it's
trying to eat her as we see them take
part in the most important debate in
this movie under acting versus
overacting propia make your case to
overact
I ask you one last time will you submit
to the ruling of this council yes yes
now in first make your case for other
acting and as Empress this is how I
decree Izmir shall be run from this day
forward hmm well that's really was
terrible propia let me hear your
overacting again is now not the time we
should act and down with the times
mm-hmm embrace your under acting do you
would find the wisdom to see that the
path I proposed her is near is the right
one hmm over relinquish your septa under
the man who convinced you to take the
scepter from me
well I don't see any point in choosing
you're both equally terrible
how wonderful for a pencil I am you know
it meanwhile at the keyboard elf train
we come across an elf played by Tom
Baker who is healing all the soldiers it
won't be so bad except for some reason
all the soldiers can see during the
healing process as this
after that Ridley and marina
talk about the artist formerly known as
snails I'm sorry about snails yeah I'm
sure you are
he died for a good cause a good cause
alright movie just keep telling yourself
you're trying to make us feel bad for
Marlon Wayans this is easier said than
done
fact is not even easily said you're
wrong you're wrong mate just because
some mages are evil does not mean they
all are I'm not I'm not if you turn to
what comes fear I'm not a mom I'm not
and now because you demanded the all
quacking choir not you not for a mage
pretty smart it turns out talking about
dead people get some pretty hot as they
share a kiss with each other thus we
finally get to that cave where the red
scepter is held and Ridley uses the Ruby
to open the door he comes across a
skeleton holding it in his hand
ah why do you disturb the rung of supper
you save e'en per visitor behind anyone
wields the power of the rod shall suffer
a horrible fate and remember to ride the
Pirates of the Caribbean at Disneyland
but unfortunately minty-fresh crest
shows up and takes the rod away they all
transport back to the Emperor's where
something about controlling and fighting
dragons is going at I don't know and
just enjoy irons overacting
ah that's good but it's no gym you even
understand what he's saying during these
scenes yes Daddy oh I just shit my pants
wait wait I can work with it my
character would shit his pants
yes yes ah ha ha I just shit my pants ha
ha so Joan of Warp sees and she can go
up there and keep the Dragons under
control while the battle continues in
the top just look at this riveting
choreography up up up up down up down up
down up down up down up down down up up
down this is sounding like a Chico to a
Nintendo game
and by the way you have something on
your garage your ladyship but you're
never on verinha
good god man did you graduate from the
doctor Insano School of Acting
now I'm new reign of terror begins my
brain I'm turning into a human vibrator
my sister my daughter my sister
I'm so talented a mr. Ridley oh I don't
know I always thought he was the
talented mr. Ridley
but Ridley gets ahold of the scepter and
destroys leaving the Dragons to finish
him off oh my god there was way too much
ham in that actor so the day seems to be
saved
I guess everyone gives a cheer our
heroes remain heroes and snails is still
dead although everything seems good I'm
gonna miss you pal and then we end with
this scene
do not question your gift your friend
awaits you
I don't get it either folks but who
cares the movie is over and my god
wasn't that a lot of fun how can anyone
not enjoy this Phil it's stupidity is at
a spectacular level I've never played
Dungeons & Dragons so I have no idea if
it followed it well but just as a film
itself
it's an unbelievable experience bad
films of this magnitude don't come
around enough and when they do we have
to enjoy them so if you want a good
laugh rent it today and see what you've
been missing out
you won't regret I'm the Nostalgia
Critic guy remember
I'm not